We're asked to order the
following numbers from least
to greatest, and I encourage
you to pause this video
and try to think
of it on your own.
Order these numbers
from least to greatest.
Well, let's work
through it together now.
So, none of these
numbers have any places,
any value to the left
of the decimal point.
They have no ones here.
0 ones, 0 ones, 0
ones, 0 ones, 0 ones.
So let me then go to the next
decimal place to the right.
So I'm starting with the
largest decimal places,
and then I'm going
to successively
smaller decimal places.
So I'll go to the tenths place.
So this one right over
here has 0 tenths.
This has 0 tenths.
This one has 0 tenths.
This one has 7 tenths, so
this one actually has tenths.
This has seven of them, so I'm
going to leave this one here
as the greatest.
We're ordering from
least to greatest.
Now let's move to
the hundredths place.
So this one, this one, this
one, this one all have 0 tenths.
Let's look at the
hundredths place.
This has 7 hundredths.
This one has 7 hundredths.
This has no hundredths as well.
This has 0 hundredths, so
this one has neither tenths
nor hundredths.
So this one is going
to be the smallest.
This one has no
tenths, no hundredths.
This one actually has tenths.
All of these-- these three in
the middle-- have no tenths,
but they have some
hundredths, and they all
have the same number
of hundredths.
7 hundredths, 7
hundredths, 7 hundredths.
So now let's look at
the thousandths place.
This one has 9 thousandths.
This one has 0 thousandths.
And this one has 0
thousandths as well.
So out of these three,
this one is the largest,
because this one actually
had some thousandths out
of these three.
Now let's go look at-- we have
to pick between these two.
Both of these have no tenths.
Both of them have
exactly 7 hundredths.
no thousandths,
but this one has
9 ten thousandths
while this one has
no ten thousandths.
So this one is
less than that one.
And now I'm done.
I think I have ordered the
numbers from least to greatest.
And the key here is go
to the place value that's
most significant--
I guess you could
say-- that has the most value.
So that was the ones place.
Compare them on that.
Then go to successively
smaller place values.
Keep going to the right,
and keep comparing them,
and then you'll be
able to order them.